[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
the murder of beauty queen tara
grinstead as it related to his
relationship with bo dukes how would you
describe their friendship i would have
described them as best friends ryan
duke's relationship with bo dukes takes
center stage in the georgia case and a
sexual assault victim tells her story
jonathan had said they're caught this is
the most embarrassing thing ever
he he said to me look batali is calling
you mario talia he's go over there and
delete the photo
and did you go over there i did go over
there as celebrity chef mario batali
stands trial for sexual assault plus
johnny depp's attorneys have a powerful
reaction when ex-wife amber heard
mentions kate moss while on the stand i
just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him but first a nationwide
manhunt comes to a deadly end the newest
details in the search for corrections
officer and inmate on the run law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer a
nationwide manhunt ends with a murder
suspect in custody with high-speed
police chase and the death of an alabama
corrections officer
it all started on april 29th when
corrections officer vicki white and
inmate casey white disappeared the pair
were not related but have been involved
or may have been involved in a romantic
relationship they were last seen leaving
the lauderdale county jail when vicki
white took casey white for a mental
health evaluation officials say she
planned to see a doctor after dropping
off casey white because she was not
feeling well but after that neither one
returned to the jail this led
authorities on a days long manhunt that
ended in evansville indiana where
surveillance video caught casey white on
camera at a car wash after that the pair
led authorities on a high-speed chase
that ended in a crash according to the
u.s marshals service casey white emerged
from the crash saying quote please help
my wife she just shot herself in the
head and i didn't do it vicki white
later died in the hospital of what
appeared to be self-inflicted injuries
an autopsy was set to be performed on
tuesday casey white was taken into
custody following the crash at the time
of his escape he was already charged
with two counts of capital murder from
here he will be extradited back to
alabama where he will be arraigned
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and co-host
terry austin bernard a self-inflicted
gunshot wound to the head are you buying
that what ex what evidence could we look
at to see whether or not vicki white
actually took her
life allegedly a self-inflicted gunshot
wound because we still have to see and
see the evidence that exists that shows
that it was actually her who actually
inflicted this self-inflicted gunshot
wound but one of the things i want to
know was it's her left side her right
side is she left-handed is she
right-handed also want to know the gun
itself who who does the gun belong to is
there any other dna or fingerprints on
that gun does casey has his fingerprints
or dna on that gun but most importantly
right now i want to know was it to the
left side or the right side if it was if
she's left-handed and a self-inflicted
gunshot wound was to the left side and
she's on the left side of the car at the
driver's seat then that is clear and
convincing evidence that it was
self-inflicted but we don't know we just
have to wait and see i'll throw out
another one gunshot residue whose hands
is it in is it in
casey or vicki's terry what happens to
casey white's legal troubles now
oh well he has a whole slew of
additional legal problems here we
already know as you mentioned that he's
been accused of counts of capital murder
now he is going to be accused with
escape from prison he could be accused
of reckless endangerment in connection
with that car chase
and we know that there were weapons in
the car and so he could be charged with
gun as long as we think that those
weapons might not be legal he could
definitely be charged with having a
legal weapon so a whole lot of
additional charges he's facing and of
course if they think that he killed
uh ms white the
police officer that could be an
additional charge yeah we'll see how
that plays out if the death of a
correction officers is a serious charge
something i think both sides are going
to want investigated quickly and getting
an answer as soon as possible thank you
both still ahead on lawn crime daily
celebrity chef mario boutali stands
trial on charges of sexual assault but
first we take a closer look at amber
heard's testimony why did depp's
attorneys have such a strong reaction
when his ex-wife mentioned kate moss
that's a head on long crime daily
[Music]
welcome back the johnny depp versus
amber heard trial is in recess this week
but there's plenty to talk about
including a british supermodel and x of
johnny depp's possibly being brought
into the trial law and crime's angel
levy is here to explain antoinette
well brian just a little bit of history
for you here concerning johnny depp and
kate moss they dated from 1994 to 1997.
and we hadn't heard kate moss's name
brought up in testimony until amber
heard said her name while she was on the
stand
heard had claimed during the uk trial
that she had been told by two people
that johnny depp threw kate moss down a
set of stairs so we tried to find out
what all of this could mean
in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs the mention of
supermodel kate moss by amber heard was
a cause for celebration by johnny depp's
lawyer ben chu in a fist pump seen
around the world chu smiled broadly as
did depp when heard uttered the words
kate moss plaintiff's attorney catherine
lizardo explains what could be behind
that courtroom moment i think the reason
why ben chu was very excited about it is
because
amber heard might have just opened the
door regarding prior bad acts because in
civil litigation you cannot bring in
something that the parties did before
the incident to show that they have a
propensity of doing that because it's
prejudicial but bad acts by whom that
might have opened the door as to her
prior bad acts as well because it's my
understanding that there were
allegations of domestic abuse against
her and her female partner before in
2009 heard was charged with a domestic
violence incident at seattle's airport
involving her ex tasia von ray
the charge was later dropped heard said
in a deposition there was zero domestic
violence and the charge was trumped up
now back to depp and kate moss people
magazine described the relationship
between moss and depp as passionate but
also described heated arguments the
magazine cited one incident in 1994
where depp was accused of trashing a
hotel room moss was there but not harmed
a judge dismissed a criminal mischief
charge against depp and he paid for
damages to the hotel room in a 1998
rolling stone piece depp described his
friendship with writer hunter s thompson
quote i remember laughing constantly he
zeroes in on faults and good points
immediately i was with kate and i think
he went straight for the romance jugular
like whether i beat her enough i
probably told him yeah she gets a severe
beating
moss has never accused depp of domestic
violence and told vanity fair in 2012
that she cried for years after her
breakup with depp
there's nobody that's ever been able to
really take care of me she said johnny
did for a bit i believed what he said
and that's what i missed when i left
years and years of crying oh the tears
maybe because kate moss might testify as
a rebuttal witness for johnny depp
and maybe that's why i haven't heard
back from kate moss i reached out to her
agency to see whether or not she had a
comment whether or not she would speak
with me about this and to date i haven't
heard back from her as for that comment
attributed to johnny depp in that 1998
rolling stone piece
i haven't been able to get a comment
from depp's camp but sources close to
johnny depp have told me
as late as late as last week and even
again today that kate moss remains close
to johnny depp they are close friends
she is supporting him through this trial
as she did also in the uk trial brian
thanks anjanet terry hurt is imagining
something that by all accounts was a
rumor so what does that give depp the
ability to do on cross-examination
oh there's no question that depp's team
is going to cross-examine herd on that
very issue of kate moss they're going to
ask her okay so you mentioned kate moss
and what was your understanding of that
incident and she basically is going to
have to say it's all hearsay she has no
understanding of that incident from any
sort of personal experience and if she
goes down that path and she tries to say
that kate moss in fact was subject to
domestic violence the next thing they
absolutely can do is try to disprove
that by either bringing in kate moss or
asking her so for any sort of uh support
of that and she's not going to be able
to do it so i think she opened the door
to that character evidence i think the
judge probably said no unless the door
is open and that's what happened here
yeah
i know that this case has had a lot of
major names on it that have not come to
the stand should we actually expect kate
moss or other exes to be brought into
this trial to say who in fact has a
history of abuse don't forget that that
that little bit that angenette brought
in that uh
amber heard has some skeletons in her
closet
exactly so it's all going to depend on
how the judge rules i think what
happened before is that the judge
wouldn't allow prior bad acts in regards
to other people unless the door was open
and that's why they got that fist bump
once she mentioned kate moss what i
would do if i want on on johnny depp's
defense team is number one you want to
make sure that if you are going to call
kate moss that she's definitely not
going to say anything negative about you
that there are no articles out there no
interviews out there or no conversations
out there that will be contrary to what
she's going to testify to i will also
ask the judge to allow johnny deppsky to
definitely bring out that prior bad act
that even though she those charges were
dropped at least be able to question her
because she amber heard was the one who
opened up that door and as of now is
johnny depp who's prejudiced by her
statement
i know many people are still wanting
their fix of johnny depp and amber hurt
tell us about the podcast law and crime
is producing about this very trial
well it's a week off the trial right
judge s karate has a conference but we
are still producing content both on our
youtube page and on law and crimes
sidebar podcast you can find that on
apple spotify youtube google anywhere
else you get your podcasts we have a lot
of content we're producing this week to
get everybody through and to give them
more context to the trial thank you very
much big information especially as we
look forward uh to when
cross-examination begins thank you
everyone coming up on law and crime
daily the alleged sexual assault victim
speaks out in the trial of celebrity
chef mario batali plus accused murderer
ryan duke faces trial as the first
witness takes a stand in the georgia
courtroom
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back a verdict is handed down
just one day after celebrity chef maria
batali's accuser takes the stand batali
was found not guilty of forcibly kissing
and groping natalie teeny while the two
took a selfie together at a boston
restaurant five years ago the celebrity
chef well known in the new york
restaurant scene grew to fame through
his work with food network and on abc's
cooking show the chew he's been at the
center of the several sexual assault
allegations only one of which resulted
in an indecent assault and battery
charge for the alleged assault of teeny
as the trial judge at the trial began
monday morning battali waived his right
to a jury trial meaning the judge alone
would decide the case then teenie wasn't
shown on camera when she was called to
the stand as the first witness to
testify she told the judge what she said
happened after batali saw her sneak a
picture of him over her shoulder
jonathan had said you're caught this is
the most embarrassing thing ever
he he said to me look batali is calling
you mario batali he's go over there and
delete the photo
and did you go over there i did go over
there when you
went over there what happened i started
walking and i was like hey i'm so sorry
i can delete the picture right now like
i didn't mean anything of it and how did
he respond to that he said no it was
fine no no worries and hey let's
actually take some selfies instead what
hand were you taking those selfies with
i was taking them with my right hand
okay and mr patel is on your left side
yes okay and in many of those those
photographs you can see mr valley's left
hand pulling your face
can you tell us what his right hand was
doing yep so his right hand is all over
my breasts all over my rear end in
between my legs um
grabbing me in a way that
i've never i've never been touched
before like that like like squeezing in
between my legs squeezing my vagina to
pull me closer to him like as if as if
that's a normal way to grab someone just
between the legs to pull them towards
you
on the next episode of law and crime
daily we will take a closer look at that
not guilty verdict which was quickly
returned
terry do you think the verdict would
have been the same if this was a jury
trial or did batali choosing a bench
trial win the case for himself
you know what brian you hit it on the
head i think choosing a bench trial
definitely won the case for him the
judge is only going to look at the law
the judge is not going to think about
any sort of
passion or or any sort of sympathy as
far as the victim is concerned just the
law and i think one of the things the
judge said is that this was influenced
the credibility of the victim wasn't
something he thought was significant he
said that he thought that she was
influenced by money and that she brought
this civil suit so i definitely think
that uh he chose well and that the judge
only looked at the facts in front of him
and nothing else yeah bernardo so the
judge kind of already hinted what his
his decision was uh but with the speed
of this verdict do you think that it
could also have been that
maybe the prosecution didn't make out
their case or was it strictly the
credibility of the alleged victim here
so the verdict was a combination of two
one that the prosecution didn't meet out
their burden they had to prove their
case beyond a reasonable doubt but
remember with any case credibility is
that issue and when you're dealing with
the victim in this case who will be the
sole witness in this case the judge just
said and found that the credibility of
this alleged victim there were many
issues with her credibility and that
even though mr bartelli wasn't at his
best on that day it was disgraceful how
he was acting that day that still the
government had not proved their case
beyond a reasonable doubt all right
interesting like we said we will discuss
more of mario batali's case uh with the
verdict on the next episode of long
crime daily when we come back witnesses
take the stand in the georgia case of
ryan duke
more than 10 years after beauty queen
tara grinstead went missing
[Music]
welcome back witness testimony begins in
the trial of ryan duke the georgia man
accused of murdering former teacher tara
grinston
the case gained national attention in
october 2005 when grinstead went missing
following a local beauty pageant for
years the case went unsolved until
podcast up and vanish created a renewed
interest in the case by 2017 former
students ryan duke and beau dukes were
arrested and charged her murder the pair
are not related but were classmates
prosecutors say ryan duke confessed to
killing grinstead saying he broke into
her home and killed her after a burglary
went wrong after that beau dukes helped
burned her body in a pecan orchard
duke's attorneys later said he was under
the influence of drugs during the
confession in 2019 beau dukes was tried
and found guilty in connection to
grinstead's death on monday philip luke
a former student of grinsteads explained
the dynamic between ryan duke and beau
dukes
brian had a reputation as a peaceful
non-violent person
he did
and he had a reputation for being
trustworthy
i would agree yes
overall ryan was considered a nice guy
yes polite
yeah
he also knew bo dukes at the time miss
grinstead disappearance didn't i did
and other people similar to ryan sort of
friend groups overlapped and people you
knew knew
sure
beau had a reputation as a liar didn't
he he did
and as between mr duke mr mr ryan duke
and mr beau dukes
beau was considered the more dominant of
those two individuals wasn't it he was
while defense attorneys painted bo dukes
as the powerhouse in the relationship
luke zeroed in on ryan duke's
relationship with beau dukes on redirect
so the
fact that you indicated you thought he
was a good guy what was that based on
my interactions with ryan
before she went missing
and you don't recall indicating to me at
some point
do you recall indicating to me at some
point that you were concerned about your
suppression issues
prior to the friendship or missing
i
don't believe i did but i
i can't say for sure
when was the last time that you've
actually interacted with ryan duke
well before ms grinstead went missing
maybe 2004 so i just want to be clear in
the statements that you made about
ryan's personality
do you really know what ryan was like at
all in october of 2005 i do not
[Music]
his um with beau dukes how would you
describe their friendship i would have
described them as best friends
bernard in duke's attorney's attempt to
paint bo dukes as the murderer how do
you think they did after this witness
and so after once the redirect took
place i think they were able to fix the
with the damage that took place during
cross-examination either way you can't
deny that both of these guys were still
friends and when it comes to this case
in fort penny and for a pound ryan duke
is going to be held accountable for the
actions of both of them yeah for a penny
i think in for a pound it's a great way
to describe this case terry does the
personalities of the dukes
and who may have pushed the other to
commit this crime even matter at the end
of the day
you know that's another good question
the personalities really shouldn't have
anything to do with this it's like that
character evidence that really shouldn't
come in from a legal perspective you
want to look at the concrete evidence
and so you want to look at and you hope
that the jury is looking at the dna
evidence that they're looking at the
cell phone records they're looking at
and listening to witness testimony you
don't want them just thinking about
personality
having said that i will say you can
connect personality to the motive and if
you recall during the opening statement
or the defendant here for ryan dude the
defense attorney specifically said look
this case is about power and it's about
influence and one of the things she said
is that ryan has neither and she said
that the state and that beau dukes have
both and what she's actually trying to
do
is to say that ryan was manipulated by
beau that he had nothing to do with it
that he didn't take part in the killing
and even that he didn't take part in any
part of this murder so we'll see who
wins out at the end which of the dukes
prevails
we'll see how it plays out thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you